um so
i was obviously a couple of minutes late
anyway so i was looking in the invite
and thinking oh god this is zoom as well
isn't it
so yeah
okay maybe kelly's reassigned people to
another group
in the second round of the signing so
maybe we'll just um
we'll make a start and then other people
may join but
yeah i'm sharing my presentation aren't
i that's what i'm going to do as well
yeah oh gosh how many things have i got
open now that's the air
okay
notice i've got they've got the last the
last slide open unhelpfully
let me uh given it all away i've given
it all away hold on
let me do it from the beginning um
obviously just to be conventional
so um okay so we don't need to do
introductions do we because we did all
of those um
uh quite thoroughly in in the main
meeting
so what i've got really here is um
is a set of um relatively bland
slides um which is i take full
responsibility
for um uh with sarah's input that
they're
less bland than they they would have
been um but i'm saying that deliberately
because
i think what they are is a a
skeletal representation of what we know
about past
castle point and rochford and mental
health
um and so what i'm hoping is through
this conversation we can kind of enrich
them a bit and enrich
certainly my knowledge and knowledge of
uh key stakeholders and planners and
implementers
uh to do some effective things um and
and hopefully sort of
enrich also sort of with that the health
and well-being strategy and what it says
about uh mental health um
some of the slides have um data
in some of it might be interesting to
you
some of it might not be um so feel free
to kind of stop me
but what i'm going to do is uh go
through the slides quite quickly
um not all of it will be new to people
but but just to say there's kind of
three things that i think would be
really valuable to pull out
uh especially bearing in mind that you
know from a a clinical commissioning
perspective
ie in the uh in the ccg
um we you know we we
are geographically um
aligned to you know south end and castle
point and rochford
so what i'd be really keen to pull out
from my conversations with you guys to
help
enrich the mental health part of the
strategy is what is the character
of castle point and rochford
who are the key players who are doing
key things who are you know who i or
anyone else
are trying to make a difference around
mental health would need
to know um and you'll note from that
that's why i was very interested in uh
hearing from us at mega center and the
other groups who are doing
the stuff around uh the volunteers
around covid
partly because um just to be frank about
it on the back of covid some
areas uh immobilized volunteers really
ineffectively
but clearly in castle point and and
rochford they were they were mobilized
really effectively
so it's really important that tells us
something about the community fabric
which i'm keen to learn about and uh
those things are assets
which help people uh stay well uh and
prevent get
becoming mentally and ill in the first
place
and the other thing i suppose uh i'd be
keen to hear about from you guys would
be
um nuance basically
unheard of groups you'll notice there's
some very general data in these slides
but who's really out there who who
despite the fact that on
average uh castle point and rochefort is
sort of socio
economically okay and health
opportunities wise
okay who isn't and that's what i'm
interested in finding out about
so i'll nip through the slides um
[Music]
okay so these are strategic drivers
in mental health they won't be a
surprise to some people
um the nhs long-term plan really spoke
about
speaks about in terms of mental health
the fact that thresholds to access
secondary care have got higher and
higher
so unless you're seriously mentally ill
the
commissioned nhs mental health services
are going to say
you know sorry you know go and find help
somewhere else
and that's been the experience of
stakeholders and the experience of gps
and primary care
that's not their fault that's because
services have been organized in
silos driven by diagnosis and if you
like
professional qualification rather than
need
and and things aren't done very uh
holistically
and because of the demand outstripping
resource
they've had to set the threshold high so
people experience
being referred off to a specialist
service uh
waiting a long time and if they show an
ounce of improvement
uh enter entering a battle not to be
discharged i'm putting it quite starkly
but the long-term plan talks about how
we changed that
the other another thing i suppose it's
really really well and the way we do
that really is about creating more
capacity there is investment
to transform mental health services
that's some of it's arrived some of it's
on route
uh i'm sorry to interrupt you can i just
check can have you changed slide can can
everyone see a different slide because
i've still got the very
first slide yeah that's that's right
it's only the first slide
okay i wonder why that is aha okay hold
on a minute then
so it doesn't suggest to me what do i
need to do here
uh um right that's weird i wonder how
then
why it's only because on my page it
looks like it's sharing the second slide
unless what it does is
what what can you see now it's just
stuck on the title slide yeah it's still
the first time
that's a bit frustrating right what
happens if i do this
oh has that done anything
no no have you opened it as a slideshow
because if you have it takes it to a
separate screen
so you might need to share a different
screen if that's the case or
just click back onto the um
original powerpoint okay so maybe then
if i just go and do it the the sort of
the
this way oh there we go yeah that's it
yeah
all right so i've just clicked back to
fine okay then if i go on to
hold on uh yeah that's working now we
can see on your left-hand side you're
slipping through beforehand nothing was
changing so that seems to be all right
now
yeah anyway great great okay so these
are the things i was talking about so
the nhs long-term plan
um and so i was talking about you know
the sort of siloed services
um driven by kind of specialist
diagnosis rather than need
um another and how we uh talks about how
we will plan to transform that and
change that
it talks about integration um a lot and
you'll have heard about this a lot with
primary care networks i'm sure
some people on the call would have done
and we described that as kind of
three-way really in that there's
integration between
um health and social care
um but there's also integration between
uh
mental health and physical health i've
just said
as as all presenters do sometimes i've
said something completely different as
i've put on the slide there
integration can be interpreted in all
sorts of ways um
primary care networks have really i
suppose our local delivery framework uh
around which to kind of hinge and hang
services and
and an integration really means doing
things together in a joined up way for
people
um and uh and i've got in there after
primary care network social prescribing
link workers because they're a key part
of the the jigsaw
uh and the community voluntary sector so
there's um
a huge opportunity as we transform
mental health services to have a
more enhanced role of the uh
for the community and voluntary sector
so they're among our strategic drivers
and of course there are local priorities
and so if i click onto that slide um so
uh our local priorities uh through a
health lens and through a social care
lens i think um
[Music]
reflect the national things i've just
spoken about that there are high
thresholds for secondary care there are
silent siloed pathways
an example is in castle point and
rochford uh
of for every five referrals a gp will
make to secondary mental health
care only four will end up being offered
a secondary mental health service
and that speaks to a number of things
really high thresholds
um lack of capacity
uh it being difficult for gps to know
where to
place people and what that also means
that there's a
wasted time for primary care
practitioners wasted time for secondary
care practitioners reviewing referrals
that
are unsuitable and um
and of course a poor service user
experience uh
so we're looking to address a lot of
that through
um a range of ways that i will come on
to
of course the other key thing that's
been mentioned a lot on the call already
today is
is coving the role of kovid i said i was
going to whip through these slides and
and i'm uh
and i lied um but i am i am i promise
i'll whip through them now
uh because i think i think we're on the
interesting bits actually
um okay so the plans to address these
so one of the things we're doing is uh
put
ipcc is integrated primary community
care
so we have um we are placing nine senior
mental health practitioners
one into each primary care network in
south east essex
uh we're redesigning and that is to meet
the needs of people as it says
there who fall but somewhere between
iapt and secondary care
we're redesigning provisions that is
more integrated with primary care so
there's more needs-led and holistic
we've got an enhanced therapeutic offer
in the recovery college and well-being
hub
as delivered by trust links and partners
and a lot of what i'd like to hear from
you about really
is how we create a more coherent
preventative offer
uh and that in part supports patient
flow
by allowing people to step down from the
uh
from secondary care and uh
create capacity there as well as
changing the way those services look
uh other determiners to consider so i
mean i mentioned
i'd like to hear from you as something
that enriches my understanding of castle
point in rochester certainly
uh and there are some prompts there for
the kind of things we need to consider
i won't dwell on that for the moment
because the conversation will hopefully
be the interesting bit
now on to the statistics um so from the
joint strategic needs assessment
which is really kind of a joint
community
health and social care assessment of
need and
uses office of national statistics stuff
um what this really tells us i think is
that um
as i said before castle point of
rockford isn't particularly standout
i mean the third highest prevalence of
depression anxiety and people to vote
over 18 in essex well i think there are
only i think there's only among sort of
five or eight areas i can't quite
remember
but um but it you know it it tells you
it's not we're not a particular
outlier in any stretch of the
imagination
um as you can see uh um yes so
we've got the lowest percentage compared
to other districts in essex
of uh uh residents
uh reporting social isolation that
doesn't mean it's not a problem for
individuals but
there are no statistics that really
portray castle point and rochefort as
any particular outlier
um okay so just to give you an
indication here so
uh this means that um
uh 0.6 percent of the population the
left-hand
graph uh will have a serious mental
illness whether that's
uh schizophrenia bipolar affective
disorder or
or psychotic depression or another
psychotic uh
illness as you can see that's well you
know comfortably below the england
average and
and uh below the essex
slightly below the essex average um and
then
if you get look at the right hand graph
there uh where my i'm slightly covered
up by the pictures i don't know if you
guys are
um so uh it's got similar statistics for
people
uh for children and young people
okay where i think the data gets a
little bit more interesting so a lot of
people may have heard of therapy for you
or iact improved access to psychological
therapies
one of the front doors into mental
health treatment
certainly psychological therapy for
anxiety and depression and a bit of
trauma and a bit of bereavement stuff
seated in primary care one as say one of
the front doors
it's it's it it relates to one of those
charts on the previous slide obviously
not the
not the 9.6 percent people the serious
mental illness
it it relates to the to the people with
a common mental illness
i depression or anxiety in castle point
and rockford
this is just to give you an indication
of how we're seeing the impact of covid
um really um i act therapy for you sees
a lot of people it sees roughly um
5 000 people or 6 000 people a year
alone in castle point and rashford
and more than 50 percent of those
recover from their depression or anxiety
it's a
it's a busy and effective well-organized
service
and that's that's in castle point of
rockford alone that it sees those
numbers
um what you'll have noticed so the the
red line is
um is the uh actual performance and the
blue line is the plan
um the actual performance pretty much
mirrors last year but what you can see
is in uh around uh
quarter one of this year ie april may
june as you have expected the red line
shows that people stopped coming to
services they stopped seeking help for
mental health problems
this is quite interesting in the context
of the previous discussion that we just
had
um and but it surged back up already as
you can see by the red spike
i'm not going to dwell on that anymore
um but um
there it is so there are pets
friendly dog chasing chasing uh rabbit
round
my flat so i apologize for noise in the
background um
okay this is maybe an interesting
nuanced fact about uh uh
i act but i think it's certainly
something we need to consider the men
are massively underrepresented
underrepresented uh women far outweigh
men seeking help in terms of
psychological therapy that may not
uh surprise you too and people over 65
are so when we think about prevention
early intervention and the well-being of
the population
we need to consider those two facts and
how we make it okay
for men to uh men to uh reach out for
help and older people to reach out for
help
sometimes it can be generational that
people aren't comfortable having that
kind of conversation
we need to address that reduce our
stigma
okay so these are the questions that i
was given
i don't know if sarah sarah are you
still on the call i am i'm still here
so i was just wondering how much of a
rebel i can be um
so so i'm just caveat what i'm about to
say next then
these are the questions i was given but
for me i suppose i just
revert to those other three questions i
mentioned at the beginning
you know what is the character of castle
point and rochford who are the key
players that we need to know who are
doing key things that will help with
mental health well-being and uh and
calm down dog sorry uh and uh
and what is the nuance what what is the
uh
the who are the unheard groups who are
the individuals that might not show on
those
statistics because generally in castle
point and rushford things are okay but
actually there's people in there hidden
who are not okay um and
and and that's it really so that so
they're they're the questions for you
there are two further slides one is this
one which is sort of the reminder
um of what they meant the public health
income prevention concordat
um i suppose just to frame this people
may or may not be aware that several
years ago
we had a crisis care concorda for mental
health which
really recognized that um i suppose
what it said was it was a relatively
shocking starting point in
in that we had to get emergency care
right before we did everything else
people who are likely to die today
or or you know do harm to themselves or
very rare circumstances others
were just not getting adequate care so
we had a crisis care concluded we had
tried to make that everybody's business
emergency services housing
um across the board uh for instance now
we have a
prevention concordat which again is a
commitment for everyone to pull together
and that's a key part of the health and
well-being strategy for castle point and
rochford
and uh you know and and speaks to the
opportunity to be more preventative
and think about those community assets
and those key players i mentioned
so um i won't come on to the next step
slide yet
can i ask a question at all go for it go
for it yes it's over to you guys now and
i'm going to listen
so uh yeah okay several things to talk
about
um first of all i mean looking at uh
just for the
um oh god what was it the mental health
strategy that the health and well-being
strategy that was sent through on
uh options on item two which talks about
improving mental health and well-being
it doesn't seem to be any actual
reference to the prevent concord at
in there at all and i wasn't sure is
there supposed to be something in there
at all
or not or that was um
i can answer that question now because
that the strategy was
written in to end of 2017 i think early
18 the current strategy that we've got
and obviously the concordat was only the
decision was only taken to sign up to
this
la in the last year so that's why we're
trying to incorporate it into the new
strategy
but that's why it's not mentioned within
our
previous one because it wasn't something
that was considered at the time when
that previous
strategy was written so will it be put
in there in in future
strategies yeah the commitment plan for
this
is going to sit as like an appendix of
our strategy
so it will be mentioned but we're not
going to go into detail because
obviously we're going to have the
commitment plan
that we're submitting to phe for this
anyway
um so this is going to sort of be the
framework for the mental health
work as part of this new strategy and
under this mental health priority
for us anyway we're not going to
duplicate it but it's going to be
included within the new one
if that right so when is the new one
going to be coming out
then is that the new strategy the aim is
that we will
have a draft version of the new strategy
to present at the december board meeting
for final sign off the aim is for the
march next year
for the new strategy to launch next year
so
okay cool yeah all right but the main
thing for me is is is if
for the current strategy is it only
talks about the mental action mental
health disorder schizophrenia bipolar
that sort of stuff
and you know kind of it feeds into that
you know there's there's the therapy
there's a recovery college you know
there's
you you talk about you know kind of um
uh more demand than resources available
and things and there's there's this
whole prevention thing you know if we
make sure there's
that's those high-level mental health
that's kind of the tip of the iceberg
really we need to make sure you've got
the lower tiers the community therapy
and for me that is the big thing that's
missing on here hang on a minute what
about the low-level
mental health community and and the
statutory ayat sort of stuff
going on there to make sure it feeds to
prevent those people reaching that high
level of mental health
issue in the first place there where we
need to have a whole strategy from
mental health first aiders community
mental health uh you know
all the way up there for that so that
that's what i would want to see in a
strategy
go for what i prefer to see anyway so i
couldn't i couldn't agree with that more
actually i mean my you know
part part of my role is that early
intervention
and pension um element so yeah
absolutely for me i do
feel that that is missing in the current
strategy
and as you say quite high level but what
you know
what about that before that early
intervention exactly what about
everything else
yeah yeah absolutely so it was really
interesting
looking through the figure because um
part of my role is to support the essex
child and family wellbeing service and
their their you know
that part their contract is obviously
that family support element
um in terms of uh health and well-being
and mental health so um social isolation
was really interesting to see those
figures
because that um until recently that was
actually one of the priorities for the
rochford
advisory board and because in rockford
you obviously get those
uh areas of uh rurality and and and
quite isolated communities
so that's interesting yeah i question
that data as well just because it's
resident survey data and
you have to sort of i think yeah yeah
it's not necessarily a true
representation
and of the situation because like you
say i would have thought it was going to
be higher than
yeah yeah
i think that's about that kind of
looking into that further isn't it
delving into
you know that data and just trying to
understand those specific
because i think that even even if the
air is not as isolated as
so castle point for example i wouldn't
consider as isolated as
as um
there will be certain areas which
which may be more isolated in terms of
communities and
families but of course you can be
socialized socially isolated in an urban
area too
can't you absolutely absolutely yeah
that can be more socially isolating if
you're in the middle of a
you know in canbe island where it's you
know more densely populated but
if you don't have any friends or
networks or social groups you i'm
seriously isolated yeah
yeah definitely i agree with the points
about prevention early intervention
obviously the investment at the moment
is in primary care and mental health
around that and we're just about to
pilot a
role um a support worker role based with
the mental health
nurse in the canva pcn um so that would
be a
voluntary sector support worker who'll
provide a sort of bridge through to the
voluntary community sector services
and also be able to provide some
targeted interventions with those people
that are
struggling to access services but
perhaps on at the level to need
secondary mental health services so
that's quite an exciting development
over the next six months that hopefully
if it bears we'll be able to roll out
across the whole area
yeah and i think it's a really good
piece of feedback
you know on on two levels really because
because certainly in terms of the mental
health strategy which is different
to the mental health and wellbeing
strategy but doesn't need to reflect it
as you rightly
you know imply uh building a prevention
pathway is an explicit objective
and as i mentioned in one of the early
slides uh and you know pulling out the
role of the voluntary sector and having
a clearer bigger role for the voluntary
sector
is an explicit plan but the feedback is
we need to reflect that in the health
and well-being strategy so that's um
that's really helpful just just to pick
a part of it so
the point about social isolation really
really valuable
but i suppose what that's also done is
highlighted the difference between
social isolation
and the fact that the characteristics of
an area with some
small urban hubs but is also quite rural
in places
as well so is there a different i mean
what does that uh is it a really
difficult question so you know so it
might be a rhetorical one but what
you know is there a specific need for
the population because of how rural it
is is there
is there enough to do for people are
there people of transitional age or in
danger of
um you know missing out on services
because of where they live
i think transport to access services is
always an issue and obviously
with covid we've all gone digital so in
a way
people are accessing more where they are
digitally literate but we do have people
that also
um you know there is digital isolation
too if they don't have access to
the internet and um you know i'm not
very good with technology and all of
that and a lot of people do like to do
physical things so i think that the
challenge
particularly in the roxford district
area is that
um yeah transport is pretty poor great
wakering and that sort of thing to
actually get in and then south end
becomes jacinta doesn't it so
um we can't really talk about crossbow
in rockford without talking about south
end because of the geography and the way
that
you know the town is and people come
into that texas services
um i mean canby island is obviously a
particular issue of
um access off the island sometimes
mentality to get
come and come on and off the island to
access services
um and also obviously more you know much
greater levels of deprivation and um
intergenerational deprivation as well
we haven't also touched on young people
um absolutely
but i think you know young people's
mental health even in
affluent areas is a real issue and
we've talked with councillor johnson
before about
young people's mental health and the
priorities around that and
some of the pressures that schools are
putting on children to perform and
achieve
and that's just you know the phenomenal
um
impact on that and then sort of
self-harming and
anorexia anxiety all of that is
probably a ticking time bomb for mental
health too
absolutely it's it's very interesting
because i've got an
equivalence of my role in other
quadrants
and in in other quadrants they have two
boards they have a health and well-being
board and they have an early help
uh or best start board and
in south or all we have is a health and
well-being board obviously not just all
you know there's there's a wealth of uh
stakeholders that come to this meeting
but
my role is specifically more focused on
early years
and young people and i do find when i
come
to these meetings that i have to really
push that best start in life element of
the health and well-being
strategy so i think that that's
kind of something to consider in that
meant
i think you're right and and something i
mean i think
um we need to uh bring because
what we haven't got are because it's
split for the time being we haven't got
children and young people and mental
health commissioners
on the wellbeing group as far as i'm uh
aware so
sarah that's probably something for us
to take away and get representation from
my counterpart
yeah in children's mental health as well
so the point here is is that these
this kind of ties into what we're saying
earlier in that the the children with
anxiety now
are the mental health patients of the
future so we need to make sure they're
properly spotted now to
to prevent that future need in in the
future there i
what i wanted to mention i wasn't sure
if mine were going to mention it or not
but has anybody heard that
apparently there's been a partnership
thing between southeastern central essex
mind
kids in spiral open door and they've
recently been commissioned on reading
from facebook here now
um to support children young people aged
15 to 18
partnerships specialist early
intervention services children young
people emerging mental health
um so there's there's you know angular
level anxiety low mood
worries about arise from cover there's a
telephone line there i wouldn't i didn't
want to kind of step on the ladies from
from my
uh her toes and i wasn't sure she was
going to mention it or not but there
seems to be a new
service that's just recently been you
know kind of like started or will be
starting
to help people and there's there's you
know that's the whole other thing there
so
um so i wasn't sure if people knew about
it or whether it was live or not but i'm
seeing it on
somebody to it so it's cool yeah oh it's
happening then yeah yeah so
there you go there's a whole new service
there for that
could i come in sorry yeah sorry go for
it yeah could i come in very briefly
um obviously i'm doing a lot of
listening a lot of talking from my
perspective
um a couple of reasons i'm very much a
layman
perspective on this being a just a
counselor
and also my portfolio my role in the
portfolio is has being short-term
but um during last year um
i held a specific portfolio for young
people
uh in the borough and that now is being
merged into
my current portfolio of health and
well-being
and going back to the point of young
people
i mean i could spend a hundred percent
of my time
focused on the young people of barbara
you know taking away the rest and
and health and well-being perspective so
i think it's
you know that that's an important aspect
but also
in terms of talking about or the
question you asked originally about the
character
of the area castle point as you probably
well known
and most people know the demographic is
is an older population
uh it's not a younger population but
obviously there is a specific
or there are specific issues with young
people
um but the the older population
i i think is um
i wouldn't say it's not ignore is
ignored in terms of mental health but i
think it's a growing problem for us
and i think we you are professionals and
work in this
uh environment know that that that is
probably
the case so but my underlying point
i think is that covid has changed
um a lot both for young and older people
and we're identifying
issues with regard to mental health
particularly i think in older people
uh now
i say younger people because um you know
the simple for example the simple issue
of going back to school
um you know i've been talking a lot with
um
bar and bus recently about that
and they you know they're increasing
their mentoring schemes and
in schools for this term because of
people's
they expect you will have issues uh with
the pressures of going back to school
in in this environment and all that
brings so
i i think from if i were to make a point
with
with regards to the strategy i i think
the current document
is um a useful document the problem with
with strategy is as we talked about
earlier
how deep do we go how deep do you go in
a document
that makes it still readable
and some something that somebody can
pick up and understand
my fear is that if we start delving into
something
too deep then this becomes uninteresting
for the people who need this
and need to understand what's out there
for them
um but i think their things could be
things be done
to to support a strategy document to
provide information on that you know
there's lots of things that goes on
today
by social media you know promoting
um what mental health
which is it's really good so i i think
that there is that there is improvement
to be made to the document in terms of
bring it up to date
um with a covid
with the covet frame around it
um in in terms of the uh
going back to the unheard of um
i think older people i've made that
point really i think there's a lot
more problems out there and maybe we're
estimating but that's my view from
simply a layman's deal things thank you
you're a representative of the community
so that's that's perfect
that's that's that's great thank you um
okay and sarah you're still with us i
am yes you're always with us it's quite
good i feel as though i'm being sort of
looked after which is
um because are we sort of rooted in
public health
um that the well-being strategy into my
so what i'm thinking to say for instance
i know public health
have uh some psychological health in
schools there's a really robust
program and i wonder if we need to do
more in the strategy to reference
um what what is happening
around sort of public health response to
in preventative arrangements for young
people with mental health
yeah i think i mean because we're going
to create a new action plan that's going
to sit alongside this strategy
because the current one is really
difficult people to report to
and it would kind of be more about
mapping what is going on
already which we did try to do last year
um but it was proving quite difficult to
get the information from everyone but i
think ideally that's what we'd like so
that we do know what's going on
across the board and with every age
group really to understand where there
are gaps because that will help us
obviously identify where there's
opportunities
um and groups that we need to be doing
more with
um so yeah i mean that that's a question
about the format of the new strategy you
know what are we going to do are we
going to kind of define
the groups within the different age
groups you know like candice was saying
i think there is
you know a question about do we have
like a start well
um element to it so that we've got a
focus on early years and a focus on
maybe working
age and then a focus on older adults so
they're all questions that i think we'll
need to consider about the best format
for the new strategy and
the narrative and how we define um
what goes into it and then